breathing's from podcast Ville the
church what's happened now is brought to
you by me undies every year millions of
people receive the least like gift of
all time underwear but we still give it
to our family and our loved ones who
just don't want it this year it's gonna
be different
you're not just gonna get Monday where
you're gonna give them a pair of me
undies the softest underwear out there
this holiday season to get your
exclusive 20% off the softest underwear
and socks you'll ever wear
free shipping and 100% money-back
guarantee go to me undies calm / Joey
again that's me undies dot-com / Joey
and again the holidays are not always
our day we start eating stuff that we
shouldn't you got stuff to do people to
shop for and cheer the spread you need
to keep your body fuel for all the
festivities but a lot of us how do they
treat I just junked delicious yes
healthy no let nature box help you with
this snacks that are better for you and
delicious and right now today nature box
is offering the church and what's
happened now family 5050 50 percent off
your first order
when you go to naturebox.com/tyler
stacks you could be eating for you know
the holidays instead of that garbage
you're gonna be like crunchy barbecue
twist and dark cocoa nom noms and I see
I'll go and cheddar cheese crisp and
garlic plantains yummy for your tummy so
right now go to naturebox.com/tyler for
50% of the order that's naturebox calm
off your horn and I'm gonna tell you
what you got all those great gifts but
there's nothing you can give for
Christmas
that's the gift of a clean [ __ ]
that's why hello she's here to solve
your problems or your relatives problems
you have a look at one of the uncles and
you're like you know what I know is a so
smells like Ted's dead [ __ ] spaghetti
and meatball dishes that's - dude you
gotta get a portable bidet for 60 date
guarantee me and Lee both have one we
have
broken your skinny bony ass ain't gonna
break leader why waste toilet paper why
kill a tree when you can have sprinkling
clean water shot up into [ __ ] and
clean out all that fungus hemorrhoid
juice bacteria and just in case you
bumped into a victim he stuck some up
their little weekend go - hello - she
calm right now
use code Church for 10% off your order
kick that mule II don't mind the church
you bad [ __ ] I got my main man
that Christ killer your uncle Joey Diaz
and my guest tonight is my little nephew
mr. Jack Junior aka Jack I said Dorian
associated with the New Jersey Armenian
acid or yeah not the California acid
Dorian's he's in New Jersey acid Dorian
so I got I think you're my first
Armenian guest am i I'm ashamed of
myself I have a comedian on once a month
giving out group on it but I'm saying I
was thinking about that Armenians
invented Groupon people just got sick
and tired of Armenians coming oh come on
I buy it five times twenty five dollars
they have met the group on Bali yeah
yeah well it [ __ ] how much you want for
jujitsu 150 a month okay I could only
come maybe five times in what what if
what if I give you $50 ten times the
session and then I tell you okay and
then white people got sick and tired of
it it said we're sick and tired is
[ __ ] I mean he's coming in here and
juggling our [ __ ] so he might as well
just give him a Groupon and let us get
beat from the beginning its thrall to
the [ __ ] back and limits and loser
now let me lose it now in labor
this fellow man I would negotiate these
[ __ ] people it wasn't Jews I know I
grew up with uh Armenians I didn't even
know it like but in my town I don't even
really where were you i right outside of
Boston
okay really oh yeah oh god I though they
were like four or five at least families
oh well I mean I had the to me when I
came here and I her saw all these Ian's
I look what is this and then I didn't I
didn't realize my little Burbank North
Hollywood right there it's crazy because
I grew up with acid durians
Carnac as a Dorian
he had his brothers and then there was
another kid Perry slacking he was a
wrestler and I remember him because he
made a big noise when they he knocked
out four [ __ ] dudes huh
he fleet that formed and challenged him
he goes off righteous one at a time he
[ __ ] up three of them the fourth one
said no worries and the group I'll take
your word for his a Groupon yeah and
then the chronic kid was a weird kid cuz
I was friends with him he was very sweet
to me and when my mother died he came up
to me one day and he goes anything you
need I'd [ __ ] anything like how
strangle a [ __ ] die before he
was a very nice kid
and what made me stick out where he was
a power lifter so he was him his
brothers would pick up Volkswagens and
turned them around that night and drunk
I'm saying so if you parked going north
near him his brother would come pick up
the Volkswagens turn it around and park
it south so you came out in the morning
and go what the [ __ ] happened which I
can't think they were powerless this Wow
one night they ripped the bumper I mean
they always had a story but one night I
was with one of the brothers I was with
another well of the family that were
strong guys tubercles and he had gone to
brown and he was like a powerlifter
Woodberry and the other guys and I go
talking you got a mirror do coke huh and
I'll never forget this were on the
street at 3:00 in the morning he just
looked around and he went to a carny
just ripped
oh my side they're all my straw he was I
don't forget we were walking out till
4:00 doing coke laughs a mirror with
four screws coming out of your [ __ ]
nobody gave a [ __ ]
well you're doing coke you don't give a
[ __ ] what you do it off that's hilarious
you don't give a [ __ ] what you do it
enough if you really don't toilet seat
pocket something wrong you guys don't
know from time to time you know yeah we
have all types against me guest on the
show but I really like to put young and
up-and-coming guess comics that I see
and you know what man this is what my
formula for young and up-and-coming
comics this is the guys that impressed
me the guys that I see whenever I go out
guys that call me and offer me rooms
guys that I know are always doing
something you know you called me Jack
and you asked me for
if I had like give it to you yeah those
people I won't give it to because
they're looking for a [ __ ] handout
yeah you know I usually tell people I
have 20 friends but I know that work a
[ __ ] hard yeah and they can use this
week this week to probably put them over
the top they work that [ __ ] hard but
I'd bit of that situation I was a
feature act where I got two weeks of
work a month they don't pay your [ __ ]
but a guy comes along and here's your
two weeks now that balances out the math
so it's so funny how I always get a hit
up by people but it's always like a
charity case like a people and try to
say hello to me it's like a charity case
I know the [ __ ] that are out
there I see him tweeting I see him on
social media not giving away free
tickets yeah letting people know what
they do and you know it's uh it's very
inspiring for guy lately I'm inspired by
young guys I see you young guys like oh
[ __ ] I'm going to tighten my [ __ ] I mean
you inspired me and Zach gets a but I
don't know how many times Jack and we
get home from a long ladder party and
I'd be getting up starting my tweet game
at 6:00 and we'd be going back and forth
Jack what the [ __ ] no go to bed concert
no no you inspired me to do comedy your
hustle motivate me you know you always
told me like I want you to call me one
day and be like hey what are you doing
where you at you're in Vegas you know
where you're in Phoenix where you and
it's got to that level where we miss
each other because I'm working on the
road and it's it's a blessing I know
yeah cuz you're tight with Kate yeah and
it's funny kid always talks about when
she comes up here and Lee was saying
he's heard you on the podcast and you're
very good and today I was sitting there
like Lee you know what man I want to put
somebody on who hasn't been on before
just so I got a different flavor I'm
doing a movie podcast and one day on
Wednesday it's gonna be long it's gonna
be drama comedy so I wanted to add some
flavor with this week so who better than
the [ __ ] Mexican Armenian there you
go to get the [ __ ] party say
and then appreciate both you guys had me
hell yeah
plus there's the other things I had my
another thing about you you know say
what you want to say about Pauly Shore
he's always worked
yeah and saying he said bull on the
goofy side but there's people who have
businesses
we all deal with these people and we all
went to school with these people that
their father owns a business mm-hmm and
they get an accident where they get a
z28
for their 17th birthday and you're
working at CVS or the movie theater
where you work right yeah and you become
a little jealous of those people really
you you really do sometimes you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] I don't work
like oh yes the work is on Saturdays and
when he goes he gets the the
construction guys coffee and he [ __ ]
goes home alone yeah and that's what
those guys do and people [ __ ] that's
that's you know Joe jr. yeah so people
can I don't have to like him because of
his father and then what but nobody
[ __ ] likes that guy not for the hater
because they hate him he comes on here
he causes problems and he half the time
you don't [ __ ] work yeah I look at a
guy like you that you basically took
over that business yeah basically the
one that started booking certain nights
and then once I saw you on the road and
should I go gays kick it up to an extra
level because he doesn't want people
coming at him go or your parenting club
no [ __ ] I work as hard as the next yeah
you know and I told I to you on the
phone yeah whenever I see you I think of
myself and like 90 91 whatever I would
roof with my brother-in-law's
I was their brother-in-law you know they
were paying me good [ __ ] money and
the other guys were getting paid great
money because these guys want to cheat
but I had outwork everybody yeah
why because they were my brother-in-law
I coulda shown him that ten after and
gotten coffee and said what's up guys
look at these [ __ ] slaves it's good
to know the boss yeah but no I would get
dirtier than them I made sure I worked
that I got there in the first one on the
job and I was always the first one to
leave so yeah my father told me when I
got into this business he goes no one's
gonna respect you if you don't start
from the bottom so I worked the club I
swept the clean the toilets I made food
made nachos I'd sat seated I did the
deejay I did everything from the bottom
worked my way up when I became a comic I
thought it would be easier because I
thought these are my friends they'll
help me do it but no when I started
doing comedy I had hate from everybody I
would have a corner like you're not a
convenient the owner's son don't don't
do what we do you name a few comments
but I'm not gonna put them on
it's been the same like I had I had to
really prove myself and I gave myself
five years I myself I don't if I don't
do something in five years then you know
it isn't for me
so I've been every day I work hard I
wake up and I hustle hustle hustle
hustle that's cuz I'm or mean I'm
Mexican as is a beautiful thing right
there you know I'm saying it's a good
conversation yeah but I show you a
couple weeks ago and you've come a long
way on comedy yeah you know your feature
act you know good feature I gotta you
finding your roots you know people
always everybody always wants to be a
headliner that was the last thing I want
yeah I don't like because I was having
so much as a feature as an emcee I was
having such a good you show up just show
up do twenty five minutes get [ __ ] up
you drink three exactly you could do the
club three times a year yeah nobody
gives a [ __ ] yeah you know nobody gives
a [ __ ] about the feature and so you get
to work the club every night needs a no
pressure
you could work every week when I was a
feature it worked every week and people
going man it's time view that went [ __ ]
yeah yeah I'm working every week I
rather get 300 less than what you're
gonna give me the headline your shitty
[ __ ] clown all the pressure and have
all the pressure got to get up in the
radio and make believe I like me yeah
[ __ ] you yeah when you're a feature i oh
you had to show up snort coke drink and
break even it's the sweet spot they're
warmed up they're warmed round yeah oh
no check dropping nothing I just go in
there boom boom boom bye good night
you know know it's such a different and
now like I'm not stressed out but I know
I can't [ __ ] over half yeah well that
was a feature you know what I have 30
minutes I'm gonna do 15 and [ __ ]
known material good material and I'm
just gonna [ __ ] around 15 minutes mmm
cuz it really doesn't matter yeah and
then I learned that you can't talk to
the audience because that [ __ ] it up
for the Hannah and you can't be too
dirty to gizelle you can't but you you
can be dirty but a classy type dirty
it's got to get somewhere listen man
when you go to a club it's not what you
say it's how you say it okay okay it's
not what you say it's how you say
if I did calmly and my first two scenes
when I was in Seattle and Denver I did
calmly what guys would come up to be as
obscene as they can you know like so I
took this um the fetus of an aborted
baby and I [ __ ] it in the ass type of
[ __ ] like that that gets a laugh from a
[ __ ] jerk-off yeah you know it was
I'm like that's what we laughs at that
type of joke like a [ __ ] jerk-off by
Joe jerk-off you know like even like if
it's something you know that it's just a
little added extra that the audience
doesn't need yeah you know just because
Doug Stanhope does it and gets away with
it beautifully yeah cuz he knows how to
do it doesn't mean you don't how to
[ __ ] do it and all you're doing is
look at the audience faces but you don't
know there's a feature IQ lost yeah in
your mind you think you want dog I will
up there and I said are you know the
most offensive [ __ ] thing to them
just to really push my limits but you
didn't do nothing no you did I don't
like you made the headliner work harder
yeah you made you know the headline it's
not gonna work harder you just look that
bad the headlines would be easy because
if he has any street sense Ronnie
comrades his first 10 minutes he's not
gonna attacked you but he's gonna attack
the softer side of himself the one just
to show how dark and speaking you really
were yeah you're follow me you're
opening always depends as a headliner
for me when I have worked better on is
the mood of the room if the moon rule if
the two people before me have been dirty
and it's gone somewhere I might as well
open up with my dirty is [ __ ] and
payment back to my world but this is
[ __ ] years of experience you know
this is completely different and some
muscle you gotta work and you know you
gotta put yourself in a bad position and
family and I've seen you do it that's
all I love it I love it
I learned it from the Joe Rogan policy
when I first started working with Joe
Joe was the king of bad position
it was horrible to watch and he'd always
climb out of the hole and learn how the
I'm out of the hole and I'd be getting
you panic the first six or seven years a
comedy Oh do you [ __ ] ballet but
after a while you learn how to how now
make your face turn red I got over the
first two or three or four years account
of my face or turn right that's it I
lost
what's your face turn red and the
audience sees are you lost
yeah you know there's so many little
things that you have to overcome you
know the frustration you know I'm I
still a little bombing at the Comedy
Store in the very beginning like I mean
crickets bro all right did you cry ever
no I cried the first time I've ever just
[ __ ] pulled my face down and gone
what am I gonna do when somebody goes
just get off the stage you know that
type ah like oh my god and you know and
you if you address that person then you
lose it ass yeah like I never knew how
to get myself out of those binds yeah
that's all experiences and the way that
you know those clubs I did last week
over a dog walker okay let me tell you
something that [ __ ] was worth over yet
I did the Davao theater the observatory
in San Diego on the observatory in Santa
Ana and all three nights of work really
yeah it's not comedy that's standing up
no more oh so you can't do comedy for
people standing yeah okay number two
because they're looking for a chair the
whole time they're just Restless
yeah sucks even if they're fans of yours
and they like you stuck and half the
people were good but it was just barroom
Tommy for years people been hitting me
up clubs hit me up once a month hey man
come talk Club it's a hundred percent of
the door to rock club in st. Louis I
wouldn't step foot and then ado come
because it's hand-to-hand combat there's
no security there's nothing it's you
against the audience hand-to-hand combat
and there's always though you don't like
the other night in Sacramento the guy
said sticky Charlie eighteen times you
know Saturday man a couple came with
signs and said where's Lee sat at the
sign of the audience I want to thank
Sacramento the punch line this city for
a great weekend last weekend those are
great ground that's great I'm up there
great you would my laughs in Sacramento
okay yeah you know it's a it's a great
[ __ ] town for I love there on the
foot you guys are on point so if you
came to the shows at the punchline I
want to thank you personally you guys
are great but sad they made this Mexican
couple side that's at stateside with
signs that said Wesley I love it I love
it though it was like it I'm not really
going the road with you that much so my
life is still pretty similar to what it
was five years ago
it's a little different but I don't know
I get to see it and then when you went
out to take pictures on a Friday night
after The Late Show
they just erupted it when you can when
we came out it was just so cool let's go
just like the zoo today right well your
testers due to work I'm saying you got
pastelitos tonight that my main man
brought you so you can be here all night
in Cuba food yeah I got a I got a
[ __ ] uber some soli pies and uh yeah
you hit a ball forget about it then I'll
[ __ ] stop you know I want to eat them
on the way here you're gonna get in the
morning and go over to 24-hour Fitness
jump up and down far to be coming out of
yes oh yeah I can't oh my god you're
going deep tonight I mean you got left
over there I already ate ten you're
still over down six maybe six you feel
like eighteen those two still wear those
those are free ones you guys we're hard
it's like wait watch did you get 42
reaction points or 42 no boy I've never
seen anything like this though tonight
because it's in you guys set a record
for we don't [ __ ] around
you guys know there's no reason to [ __ ]
around especially before Hanukkah yeah
congratulations on it
he just jumped he just shoved he thought
it was the hands legs up what Oh
how long you been doing copy that I saw
when I got a divorce so eight years ago
and how long have you been a fan of it
my whole life I mean I grew up when I
grew up in the comedy club scene so I
never wanted to become he when I was
younger because it's like you're like oh
your dad does this I want be around I
wanna do it you know I wanted to do my
own thing and I did I opened up a cell
phone store I did my own thing for a
while and then that went on there I got
married divorce had a kid and then I
wanted a therapy because I was paying
his high child support and then my ex
took my son up north and moved there and
kidnapped him for like a year so I told
my dad I'm like hey I'm thinking dark
[ __ ] I want to kill myself I need
therapy I'm paying all these 1,100 a
month I'm like going crazy and my dad
goes are you crazy you know how
expensive therapy is he's a go on stage
cry right now on stage right now so I
went on stage that day and it was Vinny
Damon Wayans Jr and then they were
coaching me and I did it and then I felt
I fell in love with it and that's that's
it it was therapy is today yeah they go
on stage it's a Groupon it's interesting
how well did your dad have that club at
the old location we opened it in when I
was what one there was like an 86 86 Wow
yeah and then at first it wasn't it was
a Swedish smorgasbord right I don't know
I read that's all I know there's some
place you would go eat
that's all right slept that long yeah
and he goes you know Elvis came over
here either make a yeah yeah I was going
to tell you there was a costume store
next to the ha yeah nudies yeah that's
been there forever
right yeah and I guess Liberace and
everyone wonder what everybody went over
there yeah but Elvis ha ha ha
all the guy used to have a room in the
back yeah well how this would sit and
[ __ ] eat at the back but literally
like [ __ ] Bank yeah yeah he'd go back
there these are smallish pancakes
I'm 227 so well it went from Ola it was
called a Swedish more than it went to
hola amigos and then they changed it to
Le amigos and then they became ha Cafe
and then it was a funny story it wasn't
even gonna be a comedy club
the karaoke and we're dancing that's it
and then one night buddy Lewis and Kym
Whitley walked in and go hey do you guys
do comedy here and my dad's like yeah
comedy go and then he just did a night
and then it boomed they went great and
then it became a comedy club overnight
like boom crazy by accident so it's
called the ha ha before there was comedy
yeah that's because he goes I like to
laugh and my dad says it's because my
initials it's HHA which is my legal name
hugglebots Ithorian how deep some acid
Orion well you just lied to me as a
[ __ ] it's funny because I had moved
here and like laying these savage and I
had done I was a comedy still guy and I
dare the improv during the week and
sometimes I do the Laugh Factory on
Mondays then the first people to ever
come up to me one Christmas to do comedy
at that Club was the LA cabaret mmm the
over the la cámara is not see the hair
on matera on Ventura Boulevard and they
have been there forever Lee a comedy
club right on Ventura there and I went
up there one day it was [ __ ] weird
like my life was weird I get off stage
at the Comedy Store at 1:00 in the
morning what the [ __ ] you think I am I'm
dirty the guide books me
Paisley says I'll pay you 75 bucks come
on Thursday then I go up there well I go
stays the guy gives me the 75 bucks it
was all never step foot in my club again
that was the dirtiest thing I've ever
heard like oh they laughed I go when you
booked me from the comedy club that must
have been drunk or something oh I don't
know one worried about then he got a
call they must have been wrong yeah
something [ __ ] weird and then I got a
call a year later that's fun and it's
Gilbert Escobar oh [ __ ] I think those do
you know the ha ha Cafe is like oh yeah
I used to live up there because for a
while I lived I used to have a
girlfriend that lived the Studio City
and he showed it to me that's a caramel
I'm around the corner from Laurie lens
anyway Noah was nothing it was not just
for no stores already just strolling
liquor stores and I went up there
Gilbert booked me on a Saturday night
and I went up there and when I walked
alone like this is a [ __ ] mistake
this was a mistake there was no doorman
not a Late Show and it was pure gang
members from haha
sit what's up here what's that said van
nuys no claim on San Fernando a little
higher yeah it was all gang members as
the kid told me outside don't bro will
fall or something like that were ritchie
valens still walk silver bar
yeah and I'm like these [ __ ]
are getting people from [ __ ] so merit
earlier I wanted and I said a joke bro
and they turned out of me is it about
somewhere no asked one of my jokes back
you know I've been doing for [ __ ]
months and they turned on me and one guy
started heckling then another guy said
shut the [ __ ] up
so when I got off your mom so I started
a war upon the tank like what was a mate
yeah she paid me cuz you never live in
here like what the [ __ ] bad luck do I
got that's it I never doing that up in
the valley again I always have bad luck
then there was another place that
somebody booked a steak house and one of
these [ __ ] things and supposedly you
got a dinner yeah and you do comedy and
you get 25 bucks yeah so I thought I
don't forget I forget maybe diamond card
and maybe that one of those [ __ ] yeah
Dante yeah somebody like that
and the next thing you little [ __ ] we
eat and they give us a bill ah sure you
know you're a comic you or the 16s or
[ __ ] gobbler there was haha you know
you are the most expensive thing on the
menu
what do you want order anything I never
gave everything a guy gave us to $50 a
game was to check he gave us a bill for
the steak and the four beers or what I
hadn't even ran it and I was like well
you said when you call me good while
after you guys want a steak I changed my
mind
I was like that's it I got no reason at
home or two places told me I was dirty
when I caused a riot at
and the other guy don't want to [ __ ]
free through this thing he told me yes
and then as soon as I got old enough and
that my parents were taking my advice I
knew all the stories about how my
parents and well my parents
they know nothing about comedy they
don't know who's a comedian they don't
know the business they were learning as
they but I was like listening to comics
and learning everything and I was like
yo this is how it's done I was over the
improbable at 5 3 or the comedy star and
just I was before it was a comedian I
would learn I wanted to run the ha and I
learned everything and that's how I feel
like the ha has been doing a lot better
since I do I do say a lot
I put whispers that 100 you've turned a
boy comic environment now yeah I thought
I started going up there cuz they used
to give it to crazy people on Monday
nights cuz your mother wasn't there
yeah so Kasey Armstrong cable oh whoa I
started going after Moreno had it
Mike Marina I love their blood they're
nice and then case you're on stroke data
that was just pure oh my god hey hey one
day that's nice
that was [ __ ] chaos on Monday night
and the only reason why it existed was
because your mom wasn't there like your
mom was hidden somewhere they like don't
come on let's go to Vegas crazy Vegas is
[ __ ] it was crazy
I remember how was it it was what I'm
telling you it was crazy
dude I heard stories about the waitress
they were just hooking up in the back
like nothing it was just a few I don't
had to man I wasn't old enough yet well
your dad had like one night a week that
was a sound guy co-op strong I come up
here with and then I would do first I
would do Monday nights with my big night
I always loved money on it if you like
comedy if you like doing comedy I would
like I used to have a goal of sets I'd
do a week like 15 sets mmm but I push
out four and one day yeah my Monday was
my big night I could hit the store I
could hit the Laugh Factory
from the Latino night about 8:35 and
then we get in the car shoot up to
Universal City and pick up 40 bucks from
Ernie G at a trauma room Robo Rover
room that was my favorite I was even
older I would sneak in there oh it's not
Monday lights that was my favorite this
was a robo rule you could go to uh I
don't know no for the room room like
we'd go to the store and then I would
say what's the other one then I place I
told you about on Mondays you could you
could pop you could have a good night on
Monday there was a bunch of rooms meth
in the wild coyotes armor that back then
but that was Tuesday where the two 0s
there Wednesday's Monday's this is weed
if you're a comic you it's kind of weird
that every night when you're first
starting out it's like it's like if
you're into music when you're into music
Monday night you go here Tuesday
Wednesday you go here it's the same
thing with calmly and when you're a
comic and you remember those names for
the were like I started my open mic week
in Denver hmm it was at the outback on
Mondays which was a [ __ ] ugly bar and
Boulder Tuesdays I had the Comedy Works
Wednesdays at club 52 Thursday's I had
what's the Mexican joint across the
Tonight Show that they just tore down
Torito El Torito
El Torito like a [ __ ] and when
you're starving comic and El Torito
would give you no money
yeah but they buy you dinner and they'd
give you a 24-hour gives it to it's gold
so that meant that next tomorrow you
come in for lunch with five dollar bill
and he you're twenty five hours worth
and have final tip for the waitress yeah
you know or $10 tip for the waitress I
mean that's how desperate you live you
you live like that still like that fully
in combat oh I love it I love it I did a
spa the other nine for $15 dad's money
yeah gasps gotta go fifteen phone they
say it's gas might it's under $15 this
is what I'm gonna do I had to do surgery
random laughs surgery hmm and I can't go
out with the tube sticking out of my ear
cuz I don't want to look like my
favorite Martian number one and number
two I'm with you know what comics bro
don't bother somebody else lapped me in
the head ya know it's good to see and go
to Jaime you know it kissed me in the
cheek or something it's a [ __ ]
Godfather and next thing you know I got
a [ __ ] too but I mean you walk in a
room everyone
you had the respect though so I give
them a hug too so they said listen you
can't do dick but what I'm gonna do is
cuz I went out with lead for that fourth
wall mmm I went over to the fourth wall
one night we bullet he goes over there
all the time
where's that the fourth wall is an open
mic next to a sushi place at the the
rating is a question mark
it's not even the ABC it be it's easier
on your own it's a question mark but
it's it's a we read there you've brought
me there don't don't for ones that have
a bride to come there one time Burbank
and Colfax it's next to the 7-eleven
next to a police station come on back
Nicole first you go further down you go
to the five five five in strip club on
chantamma Saticoy and some are sad a
coma that Saticoy and Reseda it's a it's
a strip club with the bar bro about a
year ago I had some buddies in town from
like [ __ ] Colorado they called me
like a bit because they were staying up
here they stayed up here and I saw him
at the store and they stayed in Burbank
at that nice hotel in Burbank where all
the firefighters say that the real nice
one with a past Avenue we show and they
call me well then it's like Joey I don't
mean to be rude I know you're married
you know but do you know if it strip
clubs there I know listen I don't know
anybody hold on he called me June I got
these dudes they're looking to get the
[ __ ] polska brothel only they said
both of those places was so bad hey
there I'm sorry they went to the war
they ended up going for the one ain't
Godfather and the Canoga part which one
no the one what I like the dirt that
it's horrible but this comedy fans there
which one so if I go and they get to
talk to the girls were a little wobbly
[ __ ] yeah the one on Laurel can't get a
victory
Laurel can't think when you get off the
wall I come on VIP free ITP
I worked there did you know yeah that's
right back to my I did that work there
that place has always this times I'll go
in like either you get off to 170 it's
quarter to a yeah
you see it's open I know my wife goes to
bed at 9:30 to make a u-turn
I know let me walk in then you walk in
there bro and it's just a horror show
girls are pretty yeah
the girls are knockouts in there it's
just it's nothing nothing I mean with
the lights
they look knockouts when you go in the
back room it forget about it
I only but I think I went to the wall in
uh to pick up my ex-girlfriend unless
yeah [ __ ] that's and Plan B little [ __ ]
I go right off for some night I'm not
the one who I saw the dude who died the
fat dude who died John Candy no that was
the fat dude that same vein Chris Farley
that's why so Chris Farley I saw him in
when I went to pick her up she was you
gotta see this ah you know a lot to get
the cuffs toned down there huh it's like
three-foot rule yeah what are you
[ __ ] kidding ya in Hollywood yeah so
then I hear that one time I made a
u-turn is close to Christmas I got a big
over there it's called 211 [ __ ]
nobody's around I call Louise was
girlfriend nobody's at I think what my
head do gonna young your doughnuts I go
to 7-eleven and torture the guy or
[ __ ] even the house close the half
call it 10:30 so I'm letting you turn I
walked in there bro I paid that 18 bucks
to pay going to come in
yeah I paid the 18th to go and then they
charge you two drinks inside which is
another red thing yeah but that I forgot
if it's out all they can't show you
their [ __ ] yeah just these they're
[ __ ] again know that it's our out
never eat when some of those [ __ ] you
don't really want to see how much
they're for like seven minutes like god
I drank some water and ice at that to
[ __ ] the girls came and said hello
it's not that they're type and I get
anxiety and as I was walking out before
I got in my car started and the baddest
blonde in there pop that I should go
Joey come back in like what she goes
come back in and another head popped out
come in come in come on and I'm like
honey you goddamn we'd watch the Joe
Rogan podcast we can't believe you're
ready and please come in can we get the
one time I got a tremendous lap dance
from a girl who said I setup boyfriend
loves
and the nice boyfriend was broke a she
came up to say about my boyfriend loves
to show she was my boyfriend wants
opinions you know no no no no no I
totally she didn't talk to me the whole
night very hot very gorgeous whatever
that at the end my chicken was good by
the way
I just talked to my boyfriend he said to
give you the best dance I can give you I
said okay I have one in my pocket I
think I had like 75 bucks I'll just give
her like you eight hours a tip if I took
it out she was no no no no my boyfriend
is gonna give me money time when I get
home he told me to give you a special
one next I love she's [ __ ] completely
naked I'm sitting there turning purple
54 year old guy I can't have that [ __ ]
and I said I haven't I think I went back
one other time and notice you wouldn't
let a lot of dent other girl came up to
me how long it was this I wasn't there
the night George Perez eyed me did the
spotting you one that I went to your
club and you guys were going out
afterward so I called George because I
think these guys wanna go to a strip
club I go tell him to go up like Laurel
Canyon and I think I even did go up
there with George yeah yeah I think I
even did go up there with George that's
great I haven't gone in a long time
because was dead that like one of the
dancers i I knew over there her
boyfriend got shot in the face in front
of club it's like a couple years ago so
I haven't been back since
really yeah crazy like there's a pool
hole next to it I don't know what
happened but in the parking lot in that
big parking lot yeah then I go back yet
the guy went tapped him on the shoulder
one shot him in the face and instantly
dead I was like yeah I always parked in
the front I don't know I don't know that
I realize although I shot a movie what
type of TV show that other strip club
Larry that's would close on the Sun
which one the one I like is I'm up a
little Lord oh yeah that's that's
tourneys huh yeah dirty that's like I
know Tama
I think I shot a yeah I shot a couple
strip clubs in mind do you have that
effect on women I told you I was at the
gym and this woman in this class came up
to me and said my ex-boyfriend loves
your show and be sure to tell uncle Joey
that I watched my monkey this morning
absolutely that's a beautiful thing I
watched that monkey woman you can't be
in Starbucks with a woman that's the
Society
head cuz that lets me know that that
[ __ ] the little monkey smells like a
condom Eastwatch ever laid before yeah
and those condoms got that [ __ ]
monkey glue on them and that grows and
next thing here that you got a [ __ ]
tree grow and then you [ __ ] cut boots
or the last time usually Connolly over
four years and I forgot I don't like it
hey bro by the time listen when I was
doing coke you don't care what your dick
goes in Tehran comes up it doesn't
matter you just take your chances
yeah I'm already poisoning my body being
deemed our has a joke about did you work
on uh she seemed cool you know
listen it's it's a [ __ ] crime yeah
you know I mean last time I had like I
was crazy like I was young there wasn't
that man and I made some mistakes I know
I scratched a few times but I think my
old [ __ ] the immune system got rid of
a few diseases I caught on the right
yeah what was it she everything you know
sometimes your neck everything was on
the road though she is Pro you know
ninety even when I dated Kerala Kerala
was a great lady and stuff but let's
face it she had threesomes in college
yeah you gotta check yourself out she
was a stripper dying it was she was
about the worst of the worst
god knows what I got from her great
person that's it I'm coming over feeling
when you go get checked though and the
doctors grab what we scared to get the
worst listen if you ever been shy [ __ ] I
mean I give blood tests to [ __ ] like
that one time I gave a blood test night
old man syphilis
oh [ __ ] I'm like I can't because I've
been waiting for 10 years
oh so that's wrong how did you get it
from like a toilet thaw and I went and
then they said no it was a mistake huh
oh that's the only time before we had
the baby yeah before I had the baby I
had to take a drug
to see if the baby had some but no no it
was a mistake there's no [ __ ]
syphilitic this I I just recently got a
life insurance from my you know my kid
and I did the whole full test and I was
like nervous like I drank I've funny huh
and then the they're like oh my god you
qualified for the highest you're perfect
and I was like really like I'm like
you're lying I'll either 32 yeah see a
young just dull slogan yeah so it was
that I was I was like surprised my oh
thank you like yeah yeah I'm happy child
is your son though he's eight
he lives up there he lives up north I'm
gonna see him this weekend for a
Christmas a Christmas play you got beef
with the wife no no we're good now oh
Allah we had beef and then I kept losing
every time you know I was like there's
be friends and we became cool and or
good now it's great it's like we're
actually really good like I'm happy for
her and her dude she's remarried as a
kid amazing it's the best the best thing
that when your ex moves on it's it's
it's why get jealous go leave it's like
the I'm so happy for you know and we're
friends now we're good better than ever
I told her I said Oscar is the best
thing that happened to us you know like
it we're good
you know I'm saying oh yeah real uncle
right your sister in Chicago had the kid
and my strata kid my uncle
how [ __ ] up is that it's crazy I go to
Chicago one day check into a hotel a
little hotel downtown no big deal
get on the elevator a little bit opens
up I look at your sister really on the
fourth floor she goes what are you doing
in a little with the way you doing it
what was she doing this because I'm here
visiting my boyfriend for a weekend no
way this had a beast I can be in town
here this is way before could have
prevented the pregnancy no no this is
way before she got pregnant
oh wow she was yeah I saw on the fourth
floor she goes where you performing I
know it's Amy's then she just closed
hanging around the corner I go bug stop
you know you live around company the
last thing I do see some [ __ ] commie
yeah
now she actually really enjoys it she
isn't she lips she didn't put the time I
put him know but you know how you living
it yeah yeah you're in it at four nights
a week and you guys a hit nine year and
comics for being cute around yeah I get
the [ __ ] old so I just told I go yeah
I'm around the corner but you know all
the [ __ ] I show up how about you you're
funny you changed oh no I just didn't
want that no I don't want to felt like
she had to go what he's [ __ ] crazy I
saw on the hotel
that's cures alone she was alone it
wasn't like she was with a guy in jail
and she's married as a kid in Chicago
she left everything here and went over
there and it's she's how fat you know
there's a lot of young kids that listen
to this podcast but I tried to totally
you like to change in a [ __ ] blink of
an eye
yeah she left her family better
everything for the better or for the
worse you know you know for the better
or for the worse you know it's it's it's
like when I leave the house I'm really
appreciative mmm because I had one of
those days when I left the house and I
came back the cops are looking for me so
you learned that you know every day
could be something completely [ __ ]
different when you leave the house you
might go to the corner and a guy runs a
red light he pulls a gun yep and he
doesn't shoot you but he's having a bad
day you never know you never know never
[ __ ] know man that's why your day
always has to be planned your roots your
escapes nah yeah I'm always looking back
every time I walk around oh yeah me too
I paid so much [ __ ] attention and
it's not even because of terrorism or
whatever it's something that I picked up
growing up as a kid in New York City
yeah I pay attention to everybody when
I'm walking on the street I'm looking at
that bond but I'm also looking at why
that guy stand in a corner
I'm not attentive to him he doesn't know
I'm watch him but I'm watching them man
[ __ ] that's how I was in London two
weeks ago I went to London in Paris and
when I was there I was like a military I
was with my girl and I was walking but I
walked behind me like I was just like on
point no matter what I would I would
[ __ ] and go to Paris right yeah
the capital [ __ ] blowing [ __ ] up yeah
that's New York what happened in New
York today
uh-huh you know yeah that I'm onstage
goofing around and I'm not goofing
around then not going to stop till they
blow up [ __ ] in New York something
[ __ ] stupid I am so scared of New
York which omerta matter was suddenly
you're looking at like somebody poison
this [ __ ] soda I look a little so
like Jesus I wish I'd to coca-cola yeah
but you could tell I know you've been to
New York lately oh you've been to New
York lately I've been here you know two
weeks early tried to blow it up the
today didn't they tell a they did you
know many times I was that [ __ ] Port
Authority you know that guy wore the
bomb on the [ __ ] train mm-hmm listen
we I love you they love being [ __ ]
active and I love all that [ __ ] I did my
trance I did my a trains already I did
as many as I'm gonna do in my life the a
train runs north and south on Broadway
and they have va Express and the a
regular which stops that's the one you
take when you want to do the comedy club
yeah or unless you want to go to these
village or yeah but that's the one that
stops close to Caroline's and all that
you could walk or take it so I'm gonna a
train guy and whatever what the Yankee
Stadium but I forget that one and
whatever with that a Shea Stadium those
I took him up train so now that guy had
the thing on in the Train then he went
to Port Authority don't poor authorities
like I'm a Monday morning eight o'clock
in the morning but oh my god that's
buses coming from all over New Jersey
the Bronx Brooklyn trains landing
downstairs that that that's complete
[ __ ] taxis cars
taxis cars hotdog stands your likes
nobody times I walked out of those doors
when I saw that today because I saw that
4:30 in the morning when I got up it
already happened yeah I called my lease
she was going to work I know she goes to
work or whatever phones wouldn't go
through I finally got a hold of her at
about 11:00 and she told me
that she was just and she was the
Lincoln Tunnel when I went down ah
so no no if you live in New York dog
keep your [ __ ] eyes open you'd be
very vigilant because this is the season
when those I don't know the backstory
I've been home or that was busy all
[ __ ] day but just to let you know
that that [ __ ] just petrifies to [ __ ] I
mean what happens and now in today's
world you [ __ ] and I've said
this a thousand times with your phones
out in the daytime walking around not
paying attention I took everything I got
Twitter on the phone and mic and the
real important hotmail the old hotmail
but when I give to [ __ ] the agency
[ __ ] everything else I could care less
what's on Facebook yeah Travel I'll even
take Facebook would be hella break a
computer table all right I bring the
iPad not a bone soldiers we're just
walking looking down yeah looking at
I'll [ __ ] I pay attention to everything
I don't give a [ __ ] in today's world you
have to bend but and you're traveling a
lot now correct yeah I'm gone three
weeks of looked at least you know I'm
already booking my calendar for next
year I got a couple dates on don't good
you know who's doing New Year's at your
dad's Club I don't know no yeah thanks
still open yeah Christ I'm not gonna be
I'm in Vegas that week
are you really I'm a deadly comedy club
well that would put no I mean Adam
hunter okay yeah and then I'm headlining
a one show on Saturday at 3 o'clock
early show happy hour show in the
afternoon yeah [ __ ] want to pass a
coupons all day I saw you on Instagram a
month or two ago in Vegas you picked up
a show from my show yeah look for a cops
or something yeah I did a I was in Reno
and I was performing at the Laugh
Factory and then this whole front row
was just heckling me and we're going
back and forth back and forth and it was
a great show at the end of the show they
go hey just to let you know we're not
truck drivers were cops and I said [ __ ]
you they're like no we're really cuffs I
said get the [ __ ] out oh they're just
drunk they all pull out their badge like
at the same time and that we're not even
cops with detectives and as a holy [ __ ]
are you guys serving me again I'm like I
was like scared and like no we're here
for a convention and then they go
you want a party I'm like [ __ ] yeah we I
went to their hotel with freaking
drinking all night and then they had me
performed for the whole convention for
like 800 people for a honor cops and I
did it they give me a plaque it was one
of the best experiences ever a [ __ ]
plague dealer stucco golf in two weeks
oh yeah I got a couple planks of my day
what's the code gets stuck at 11:00 I
get pissed off oh my god damn it
they used to be mirrors in the 80s that
had designs on it yeah especially if you
have a friend in prison that's what they
send you what if you have a friend
that's in prison that's what they send
you for prison it's a mirror that you
could see yourself with but at the same
time there's a design or something so
let's say you really like that album
cover the Sabbath bloody Sabbath with
the skulls is [ __ ] don't put that in the
mirror oh yeah so one year of somebody
sent me one huh he was in prison that
was his gift to me and I'm living I'm
living it's though I think he's in jail
it took me eight years to make I lived
in snow bass and he had done something
he had been in County for examle days
they'll have sent them I put money on
his books and that Christmas he sent me
this [ __ ] mirror and I held on to
that mirror for three years I didn't
know why but between you and I I knew
eventually I was gonna get the snort
coke off this nervous yeah right he like
he's he gave it to me like in I don't
know maybe [ __ ] you could have done
that the first night Joey though he gave
it listen to how crazy says he gave me
the mirror
he was doing time in 83 I helped them
out and then like that Christmas I got
like a box at the [ __ ] door and it's
him from Cali jail it's like a mirror
I forget who the [ __ ] was on that thing
anyway I gave it to I leave it in my
room I moved to New York
my buddy puts it all in a box and when I
come back he is later he gives me the
box so I move into my new place in
Snowmass Village and sure enough one
then I see that [ __ ] mirror I
couldn't find a good good mirror and I
saw that man and me the [ __ ] I can't
read colors in addition and I took the
coke left flipped over on the mirror and
I started chopping it up and next thing
you know you man oh Corral the ink from
the hot spot it makes it so usually like
berries for a paint or something you
don't think I slaughtered that pink oh
you better check this out when I started
the ink the [ __ ] glue you blew your
nose when I opened up and it was the
picture I forget that look play I'm like
I don't know if I should go to the
hospital
although the doctor and tell him the
truth of what happened because it was
God have you done that before
mentors Oh tell me you don't tell the
truth no no I never went to a hospital
God listen bro god forbid for a
drug-related day a never ever I came
close to times I'm looking a lot it but
you can't [ __ ] go unless you're on
your last [ __ ] ticket yummy drug
addicts a list is folk comes out of him
up that's still the other truck and
Jimmy how many kool kids are at the
doctor and I'm like the fires are giving
me allergies and no let me tell you
something my friend [ __ ] God I had
friends that had to go to the hospital
you know when you go home at night
you're coming down you get that you
arrhythmia in your heart that that
[ __ ] heartbeat that gets away from me
and that's a scary feeling they would
down my won-won on themselves I would
[ __ ] lame Ben and so just one away
yeah I would sup on an orange peel and
[ __ ] hopefully that
they wouldn't make my heart stop racing
and knock on wood guys I mean I'm not
proud of it because you got your you
know you're born with just so many
heartbeats that cocaine takes years off
your life is time it's like cat years
I'm really [ __ ] I'm 54 but I'm like
laying the eggs right now [ __ ] well you
got a lot of knowledge well the
knowledge was some [ __ ] rage stories
probably knowledge was from the [ __ ]
mistakes I mean it's crazy that I
started snorting coke it's 1979 and I
stopped in 1987 you really gotta think
about that nose - oh yeah I wasn't born
in lady oh my god so what is that 79 to
82 2007 is worldly yeah 28 years that's
a long [ __ ] time of making mistakes
that's a long time plus that's a lot of
party that's a lot of hotel rooms that's
all this is the people story that's like
super stories lada see I see is a lot of
sickness and no I have nothing to be
ashamed of I don't judge anybody who
doesn't I don't give a [ __ ] anymore I
mean you know people gonna do it people
gonna do whatever they do
until one day they decide no rehab we've
all had friends that went to six rehabs
and none happened yeah I just thinking
break and one day guess what they meet a
girl his three months later and it's not
the girl media they you you gotta meet
someone to change I know there's people
on Facebook I could tell I could tell
people that talk to me on Twitter I
could tell people talk to me on Facebook
I know when they're on drugs mm-hmm
I could tell there's a lot of people go
to the church website don't shut Church
what the Facebook page and they're doing
what they're doing I would never [ __ ]
judge them at all I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm happy for ya I hope they're having a
good time you're gonna do it do it I
went into a Pablo Escobar style so if
you did strong for 28 years how how many
years were you having a good time
[Music]
on those 28 years I had a good time for
18 of those you plus it put me in prison
plus it made me change addresses 80
[ __ ] times you know you just become a
slave to the [ __ ] game but you see it
now and like I said I can't tell
somebody what the [ __ ] they're doing
what to do I can't tell nobody what to
do but because I know that you'll wake
up one day know last night that was it
and whether it's pills whether it's
cocaine whether it's whatever that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] and [ __ ] your whole
life up you're gonna wake up one leg or
you know what if I wake up tomorrow and
go I said I'm not smoking weed no and I
know I'm gonna come to you guys in the
year and go you know what let me tell
you what's gotten better since I haven't
smoked weed you don't think I know that
people but I know it's the last [ __ ]
addiction it's the Last Temptation of
Christ if I give up weed I give them
everything I got nothing I changed
completely
I'm holding that the dear life just so I
could be a bad person he's I'm saying
yeah this is the only thing I still do
that makes me feel like I'm doing it was
great we did I was sure Hmong ants sure
because I'm a [ __ ] professional I'm
am i proud of it no but again over the
years that's what you can't whatever
you're living through right now you
cannot oh come on
you want me to tell you I mean you've
been doing family a is you know you
starting to see a little success you
know economy does to your head to twelve
thirteen year mark
especially when you started with people
and they've already gone to Montreal and
they're making money and you're still
little stuck yeah it messes with your
head
Harley so you know I'm not saying that I
had any right to do drugs or anything
at the time I'm not saying that at all
it's just heavy it's a heavy burden to
carry yeah you know I have nothing
against people working 9 to 5 job but
jamming 9 to 5 job you know I'm the
first we all start with zero you know
you start all over again the process
starts all over again hey what are you
doing Jack Jr yeah you got anything this
month yeah call me next week and I'll
hang up okay
hey how you doing Jack Jack let me send
you an e-mail did my valves hey you're
gonna swing by my mom's his mother to us
by yeah what about that room up in
Oregon you still got a small 850 you
know every [ __ ] month on the first
and whether your again well any any job
that you have a year on commission or
you're an owner of a job if you listen
to the show you don't talk about it
never ends never the [ __ ] grind never
ends and for a comedian think about
having to do that grind and then having
to go for the stage at night yeah that's
just part of the [ __ ] Ryan and yeah
you're talking to Joey what's the grind
consist of how bad you want it you know
I used to sport till 3:30 at the store
and then go to a place up on in
Hollywood Boulevard and sell screws and
nails on her phone so we had a start at
[ __ ] 4:30
because at 7:30 New York City tonight
yeah so you want to catch the
contractors walking it and that's the
first time I used to send faxes out to
people so Monday Monday at 4:30 when I
get there and morning I would send faxes
team-mom The Comedy Store the Laugh
Factory in those days The Improv yeah
and then you started a broad creative
entertainment
Dana done the girl whatever that Dave
Tribble now you look at me go enjoy
who's David David triples a guy who
books the Pacific Northwest this guy
wouldn't even take my calls but I still
got his facts loved and stared at the
faxes you think that they yeah yeah you
even oh yeah it didn't matter every
Monday if you were a Booker you got a
fax of me so you
your atomic right now this is a [ __ ]
free tip from the uncle Joey but no run
top or something
no let's pretend let's pretend jack is
my buddy
okay Jack is my I go to Jack's Club and
I go up there on Sundays and I go up
there on Tuesdays I go up there on all
you off nights I don't bother jack on
Friday and Saturday and I go up then I
stick to my light can I do ten minutes a
one night jackets and a bun Joey Diaz
doesn't show up so Jack tells me to
stretch and do 20 and I do a pretty good
[ __ ] 20 to be honest with you I mean
Jack is alive the audience is not lying
I'm not dirty I'm a little on the clean
side you know at the end of that I'll go
Jack bro anybody you could hook me up
with and bro you start getting these
things and I'll call you Lee and go hi
Lisa at how you doing Jack acid during
told me to give you a call or you want
to jack friends give me a call about a
month and a half maybe I'll have myself
a feature spa fee leave me a number you
know and then they don't call you back
or you know Rudy Moreno he's a great guy
yeah I got to tell there will be told me
Rudy Moreno was drew we gotta get in
with Ike wanted four times you never
called me back
yeah that's what I did I showed up at
his room like Don Corleone yeah and
pulled him aside little bro what the
[ __ ] you don't call me back huh I've
been visible when you got a guest spot
and they put you up they put me up and
that's how we released found a
relationship when it comes to comedy you
have to do things that are not unsavory
but do you have to be extra businesslike
so what I would do is if Jack told me
that Lee and I give you some names Lee
Theo von and Sarah Tiana booked rooms I
wouldn't even call you [ __ ] I
would start sending you emails every
week for about three weeks for you to
look at no Joey Diaz what [ __ ] Joey
Diaz yeah and again and again and again
and I would send you the whole month of
December and January and I'd make
updates that were important like I'm in
[ __ ] punch line in San Francisco
I never been to San Francisco what
[ __ ] punchline you know I'm saying
I'm here I would put clubs that he
wouldn't find out because there are see
room anyway yeah never see well anyway I
mean I would double check for sure that
this person didn't have contacts yeah
before I started dropping names that's a
quick if you like fake clubs um
you just say casino I'm doing a casino
over here in the Midwest let's pretend
let's pretend ours door the guest set
hahaha
for Maz Jobrani all right I would say
hey knowing that day they put opening a
larger body I'm not lying
yeah but I'm not really telling that you
do the same thing I have them that you
know have you ever you ever going
anybody here we go to a comedy show and
the comics that the MC says coming to
the stage this guy's been seen in Game
of Thrones and all sudden you watch the
[ __ ] guy on stage and you know like
I've seen all the Game of Thrones three
episodes that's ten times the piece and
I never seen this [ __ ] and after
the show you'll get up and go up come we
go excuse me doing the little [ __ ]
interlude ed you said that you were in
Game of Thrones not for nothing I did 18
episodes who I saw eighteen episodes who
the [ __ ] were you and then tell you well
what really happened was I did the
episode but I got cut yeah I got cut
because my hair was longer the producer
didn't like me
well then you need to really do the
episode yes he did yes he did if you are
mine DB there's nothing about Bronx
County shoot that pilot I shot that
pilot there's nothing about like two
other NBC shows if I put him down and
you question me you're not gonna catch
me with my pants on it's not my link
when I was looking for a job well I was
looking for a regular job everything I
brought a resume was a lot oh my god
yeah I used to put this diss uh
I'm not gonna say where they are a
friend of mine worked there and he was
like an assistant manager so I would put
down that I worked I go how we call it
ago what did you get
he time yeah often like February 86 to
March of 87 so I would put his name down
I gotta put Joey Diaz but works for
manager but my mom pop so I'd sucked him
up like they would call and they go the
Joey Diaz worked there from everything I
will go no we never had a Joey do you
see he said he worked for a joy Jack
Jimmy we got a Jack Julian oh that's
weird how could he see I'm saying here
and all more yeah so sometimes they
think about and go yeah give him a job
like sometimes they call me up and go
well they said didn't know you were at
this place they said you know you were
at this place I didn't really give a
[ __ ] man when you're trying to get a job
you do it Chad do if they catch you with
your pants on then you're not gonna get
the job you gotta have coverage yeah I
did it on a commercial audition Vinnie
was going into the audition and I was
with them and I went I just signed in
and then they all who you here we don't
have you on the list I said what the guy
told me to come and I made a hole things
that are below and then I got a call
that buy it and get it but you gotta
take chances like that boy although I've
Kranti in the old days you'd crash on
yeah that was the name of the game you
know me [ __ ] auditions i crack rats
the longer show hmm I crashed along
assured I crashed American Gangster
there's a bunch of movies I booked
because I crashed I crashed like a myth
huh you know how there was a time I
didn't have a commercial agent and one
day I called are they already do me a
big family toilet buck and he goes when
a book of being Hollywood boyfriend I
was doing coke I just got into a spot on
a Friday and I need 200 bucks it was one
night 200 southla Bram at the other one
I'm at South South La Brea doing an
audition if you lived in Lowell and now
I own the LA area whenever your audition
for
or used to be a commercial the big ones
are Santa Monica Ocean Drive mango
there'sá-- and then the one up here
Ventura Boulevard hmm and then the war
nun all over a pet dog that I would have
loved to go because I would go and sign
a cat food cat toys [ __ ] but then
there's one down more ari said to meet
him there so when I get there to take
the money how he goes by the way to say
mobsters in that room in there like know
what I want up a sign my name same thing
she came over and she goes Jose Diaz
Jose the I don't see your name on Hank
oh yeah they called it though yeah she
goes who you wick igari who you were
aqua aqua and then are I going bad my
book the commercial set I showed my
level of aqua sign me and that's how you
do it yeah nice and easy where's Tony by
the [ __ ]
[Music]
I wanna be around to pick up the pieces
how many more stars away guns
nah d0 finish them so somebody twice as
smart as
as somebody who will swear to be true as
you used to do
with me let me get some shoutouts real
quick first off to my main man Gordon
Warnock coming up and supporting all
weekend long and bringing me a beautiful
album my girl Jennifer Jones made three
types of banana bread which Leawood
delicious the one with the walnuts I
love walnuts charge and banana bread oh
you could take you you left
you got a drive and then I open the
potatoes she sent a wallet for my
daughter so she's beautiful Colin sack
note hub Street you know I love you Bob
Becky
Oliver whatever your name is ten per
cell Kevin Gilbert Brandi Lynn Gibbons
my girl
Jeremy slaves golf bit foo and my man
Jeffrey Collins are always causing
problems on [ __ ] on Twitter
today I'm saying telling people about
[ __ ] Denver and don't [ __ ] reefer
so you and this is what you want to do
get ahead of the [ __ ] club if
something happens nobody could raise
their hand you bitch-slap everybody you
know Game of Thrones it's Game of
Thrones
I got two sisters yeah I'm gonna take
care of them you guys relax it's it's a
weird thing on the comedy club is
another side of the [ __ ] coin yeah
and to see I'll never forget men and I
still think about it you know when I
moved to the valley the girl the haha
was right around the corner you guys
were having a phenomenal time in there I
gotta tell you that that was the first
time ever that was sober that you guys
made me laugh because I knew exactly
what you were doing are that you Rico
and would the Agostino who I love with
all my self I and it was something to
watch you three every night and then the
other crazy [ __ ] Vinny yeah you know
I'm a fifty year old guy my daughter my
wife just had a daughter you know we
just had a baby we were living in the
valley maybe two years I joined the
valley and I would call over there from
time to time
and I would just sit and watch and you
would always be a gentleman and offer me
something I did dad but gonna you wanna
if you want to read the water left foot
your dad loves his [ __ ] fruit lately
and I would watch you for goddes and it
was like being before me and it made me
a good you know I prepped for the
Gabriel aces show at your club uh-huh I
just told you Angus Tina just count on
me to show up late because the taco
stand was on the corner yeah son come on
you know that's right at skinnies it
causes you yeah yeah skinnies the tacos
things faster :
so I didn't add the Comedy Store then
those days I basically sat home my wife
on Fridays and Saturdays and watch TV
what you know your mother so listen as
long as he's dirty he has to be on last
on Fridays I still like them so I said
[ __ ] it for him so I would go down there
go last to 15 20 minutes and then go get
[ __ ] four tacos and hotdog that
[ __ ] bacon on it mm-hmm you know but
it was just inspiring to me like I was
going through whatever the [ __ ] I was
going through I was becoming a dad but
watch me [ __ ] well you weren't
watching you for 80 'its because that's
exactly I remember being one of you guys
and you're an idiot we were idiots
Aaron you said oh [ __ ] Jack Jr
chain-smoking on or the one oh [ __ ] I
would see because I knew what time it
was
as soon as I walk in do what you said
the funniest also I'll repeat it like oh
[ __ ] one eye on the tip jar one eye on
the register halfway home make the call
forget about one eye on the tip jar and
one of the register do we still say that
to this day it's so funny oh my god
there's you know I work at a bar yeah
there is nothing like the most
frustrated was a genius my mother was a
genius because my mother do from 9:00 to
3:00 that's your business huh if you
don't want to cry if you if you want to
save yourself
millions of dollars and anguish and
aggravation Lisa anivia
by a bar make me a promise that until
the night you sell it you're there from
life to cloth because of nothing just
gonna rob me yeah listen they just are
they they're just gonna Rob you
every today till this day I don't know
those years that I was doing coke and
drinking you know before we turned the
podcast on I was talking to Jack Jr and
I told Jack was a destroy one night and
I was telling Jack I pulled them over
letting go Jack I'm not excusing you
have anything but do me a favor whatever
you do don't do cocaine down here
because once the word gets out these
people use it as a weapon against you
even if they do with you don't do which
it don't do witches don't come to you
and go what can we get it and then three
days later you hear from the manager
listen don't come up here no more
what's-his-name said you sold them
cocaine and tried to sound cocaine
you're like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so you know it's cuz I've
experienced up there oh thanks scope to
refine dollars wait now that would there
were some nights where I had no choice
but to stay up there because my
girlfriend was waitressing so I would
stand and I'd be drinking those rum and
cokes you know if I was tape drinking
ten and twelve what do you think Jack's
drinking what do you think you're
drinking how's that bar making a profit
yeah nobody nobody nobody I saw people
who destroy bars when I work at Tom and
Corky's when I worked at Tom and corgis
where I used to hang out at Tom and
cookies really came gregory seventh day
weekend you know he wouldn't come in on
Monday nights it still made money
there was a $2 blue bird special the
cans of uber and armours juice with
vodka $2 a piece [ __ ] tremendous jack
journey we go in there with a [ __ ]
8-ball all the mud they like to watch
Monday Night Football
do a nice when I said DJ at the strip
club the manager trusted me like crazy
he'd leave for like an hour
Russian dude never came back and I would
be in charge I would literally tell the
girls just go to all the customers are
gonna have sex with them
and then when they take their pants down
just signal me with your hand and I'll
raid the room I'm like what the hell you
guys doing and we rob these [ __ ]
customers with literally like five six
eight but we we make so much money for
that hour when the manager wasn't there
and then we split it like we literally I
like you want to go to jail you want to
go home give me your [ __ ] money we
just take their mind it's on Sepulveda
[Laughter]
it tastes
that's a scary business yeah because
those are coke fiends are your those of
demented people lately they were out
there trying to cheat on their wife
trying to get a [ __ ] a strip and
they're just so with their ankles that
takes all your [ __ ] crazy and with
the flashlight with a big mag light that
big-ass one now we'll just boom come in
there and with my are mean ass you were
so you know you hear all these stories
below these places are Lankershim in the
valley where there's like Runaways and
[ __ ] there's a place for Van Nuys are
all Cuban sheiks the hot [ __ ] bro my
biggest fear is going into one of those
places they got you know they got you
you don't think they really go those
people they're not stupid damn cameras
somewhere because one that guess what
Brad Pitt is gonna want a piece of ass
one that you know walking that will
[ __ ] up and they got but a month was
that he gets a letter and they want
80,000 [ __ ] four dollars for the
[ __ ] tape yeah you don't know but
this is how you have to assume people
think yeah this will praise you [ __ ]
people out there yeah you know strip
clubs are a strut crazy [ __ ] business
I don't like them like fur guy like me
people look at me know this love I go
strip club for lights a week yeah I was
never a strip club guy because I used to
go to the best strip club when I was 16
they stuck a bland up their [ __ ] man
what you see it but that in the second
best place is Taranto Canada yeah
there's nothing like a strip club to you
go to Toronto we put coins that are know
you could bite their pubic I kept bite
that pubic hair you can't put on
monkey in my face oh and on the way back
I'd like the pubic hairs and she'd go oh
yeah I'm a savage you know I mean I
don't want to suck without only more
because I work there I know what's up
yeah you know the girls like oh my god
can you see my tampon can you hide it I
can you look under string key babe when
I go on stage and you put like bright
lights like a red lights no black legs
because my stretch marks like I know
like all the secrets so there's no
fantasy it's not hot to me no I go
there's like oh it's like these [ __ ]
are just disgusting before I left
Seattle or the best jokes ever wrote was
something about this is why being Felipe
Esparza
till this day whatever on stage at some
point is a Phillippe it will always yell
tampon fool because I used to say a joke
when I first moved down here I was
having sex with my girlfriend last week
and I was going down there from behind
makes a noise felt a little string ah
there was a put or light it that was my
joke and Philippe I used to love it
that was one of the nastiest jokes I was
then I used to go I didn't know where to
put a lighter so I let it you know what
that was it that was my like Comedy
Store joke you know so for years
Philippe with a heavy time pull the cap
off fool
I guess what the other night I did it
the Sacramento off-the-cuff I haven't
done it in 20 [ __ ] years and the
other night it came to me when I was
onstage it was those alpha brains I took
what the put the THC [ __ ] star that
night hey hey to tie like 10 stars and
twinmas between you shall win between
shows and when I went up there for the
second show I was in a different planet
the 40-minute mark when they gave me the
first light was the first time I came to
consciousness and I started getting
anxiety attack I had to tell the
audience limite was gonna let me just
for a minute and they thought I was
[ __ ] around but I really wasn't and
then I had another 20 minutes left to me
the alpha brains kicked in and I [ __ ]
just laid on eleven Billy go in Jesus
Christ that was a CD right there
I was talking about God I know what
happened sometimes you go on saying
Emily and the other thing was it was the
[ __ ] head into her I had done eight
shows that week no I did three shows up
lit up four wheeler walker and guys you
know what I do two weeks a month I like
to work out during the week and I never
took a break after the special that's
what [ __ ] killed me that's that's
lesson them with [ __ ] one there and I
didn't listen to myself and I can't I
went to New York soon as I shot that
special I should have gone home for 60
days for 4 to 3 lakhs just get your
bearings back lose all that material
lose it mentally lose it you know I'm
saying yeah the material I was doing
until Saturday night I don't know I got
10 minutes because by the time I come
back then I'm gonna remember Harvey you
don't say I lost all the everything
Harvey's gonna be in the news for a
while but we'll still work something
around the other thing we talked that
thing and they still got a couple things
I'm working with but I wanted to take
this time off it clears your mind
bad habits yeah well we work a lot we
pick up bad habits we get good we get
solid but whatnot HBO sighs yeah yeah we
get really good in what direction if
you're shooting a special over you're
preparing for something but if you're
just going on the road and trying to put
together 15 minutes every week yeah and
switching it up so you're always fresh
to the club holder and the weight snap
goes well that guy comes in here before
different sets you know if you do that
type of [ __ ] then we're talking Stone if
you want when you're doing it for a
while you get good yeah it's not always
the place you pick up bad hat
and say something during your set you
know and that's why like I get out go
you know you start going here to go
jokes yeah I want to get rid of it to go
jokes yeah and when you do those jokes
and they don't do well and then you're
like stock like oh [ __ ] okay we all have
to go joke which are jokes that we go to
the dough are ninety percent they take
you're right there the ninety percent
it's like slam dunking you know when you
know when you start going to those early
on you start to burn out shits going on
I've never burned on calm yeah I love it
too much yeah I'm just trying to get
ready for 2018 you know I mean let me
get the surgery done let me take this
little breather here you don't saying I
can't take cross-country flights for a
while you know I gotta stay close to
home can't be you know San Jose [ __ ]
like that you got Oxnard yeah you got
Ontario you got [ __ ] have more
Albuquerque for the first time nice next
year I got dates and [ __ ] Austin and
then I don't have a lot I'll tell you
that much I'm sitting at home until I
figure out what's going on with Netflix
Netflix give me a special and we're
ready
you know it's an listen it's so hard
because you're doing comedy eight years
I'm doing comedy 27 years and whoops
still struggling I'm so the same will
you up but I loves only a different [ __ ]
I'm in the same boat only a different
ship I'm over there swimming towards you
you get done with you're not even
sweating you're in another boat making
progress but your guys wanted you just
with it yeah okay my problem is I got a
good engine yeah but now the [ __ ]
windshield I got no issue you know I'm
sure you have them but have you seen
this show The Amazing Race what's like a
you have to keep doing obstacles or do
it like pet challenges or puzzles or
something against teams wow it just
seems like comedy might be something
like that like like how you you're a few
steps ahead of them on the path but it's
the same path you know and then this
when I talk about calmly I want you
people to generalize it is any art even
law school they think way you [ __ ]
gotta put your life into this mm-hmm
this is what you're gonna do for your
life when you commit to something
especially as hard as comedy or being a
lawyer or being I'm gonna commit to
painting portraits I'm gonna [ __ ] see
the family of three pay a [ __ ]
mortgage mm-hmm and keep my wife happy
and put away money in retirement by
painting those [ __ ] pictures you see
those pictures here would you do that
Lee would you look me in the face and go
[ __ ] you and your podcast I'm gonna
[ __ ] so point a kid and Paula
painting those [ __ ] pictures I
believe in myself wait what's your plan
you know what my plan is I'm gonna
[ __ ] paint different teams every
month and I'm gonna go into a restaurant
and cater it and have people come down
and pay 25 bucks around I cover my thing
and look at my art and if I sell I could
do six in a month if I could sell 206 I
could pay that and I'm like really and
you know again that's how I do it every
month and someone said you're lucky and
so awful yeah but do they figure out a
niche for themselves
yeah motivate yourself you know like I
put I want to put food on my kids not I
want to get him what he wants I want to
get in that Nintendo that's what I would
that's what motivates me every day
is it still detent though is the
Nintendo switch right now it's a new
house just this thing I bought one 325
right that's not bad that's a lot of
money I make sure it's I gotta sell do
that it uh
for me it was once I got it I got it
because it's like selling coke only it's
a different energy ya know one time when
I was locked up this black dude set to
making you're managing all the energy
you see all the energy he doin to doing
bad things thinking if you took that
energy into doing good thing yeah
never forget him time it was like close
to Christmas and we were outside it was
cold out and we all had those prison Li
jackets I would like so hooded
sweatshirts underneath and he was a
black dude I can't remember what his
name was it was the library and me maybe
somebody else check it out
no I was a Chicken Hawk there was a
Cuban kid when I was locked up his name
was Tannehill he was a [ __ ] trip he
was a gang member to sudden tanner hello
I think about him time to talk I'm I
always sit here very puzzled that nobody
I did time went from that [ __ ]
halfway house or whatever has ever
reached out to me the annulment oh no we
had the one kid the one kid that was my
roommate Pend Oreille sold and coke and
he tested positive I kept checking the
bro this is one of the funniest things I
love in the halfway house I'm about to
get married
my fiancee is pretty much pregnant okay
LM like Sammy the bull Gravano I'm
selling cars a song called thug and
enhance Li and most of my action is that
that [ __ ] a half way out of course
like till this day I still sit there and
every six months I think about this [ __ ]
and I go oh and they knew I was bringing
of it yeah I was like hold on hold on
they knew I was bringing them because
bro and I'd pull into the park like as I
even gotten to level four where I could
drive a car I was a concept yeah so they
gave me a car when I would pull in I
would see all the inmates jumping up and
down in there
where will you hide it did my ballsack
oh wow and I put a half ounce in [ __ ]
ribs at my balls tonight a half ounces
broken up right all integrands
walk in the building everything would be
[ __ ] done and then one of the guys
was my room man his angle of being awake
oh that was though he was shaving oh my
god so he would sit there from 2:00 in
the morning the six would steamer
and every hour the guard would come and
go oh well you do it
shaven how can you be shaven because
he'd be sweating
[Music]
so you keep doing that don't piss you
yeah I would [ __ ] with them from time to
time just to test them every time I
stand up past two next more than I had a
piss test
like [ __ ] automatic so I knew if they
saw me up past [ __ ] 11:30 I was
getting a piss test yeah
so I would always do blow and lay down
and just jerk myself off and just look
at the star as the make sure I would pee
before they would come in the room yeah
hatch you pant you're getting the best
at yeah are you gonna piss test
that's fair so it was crazy dog that was
their psychology why are you up watching
TV and if you beat him 10 times then
they would stop ah but they would bang
you up
I had a neighbor in one of the rooms
that was clean and sober and he was four
he in fact he yeah he's funny have an
injunction against them because guy he
was genuine he was just calling it like
prejudicial he was white dog this dude
was white and smart intelligent he had
cash so he said every time I'd stay up
past he goes I'm a [ __ ] Nighthawk he
goes look at my prison with my god
they're like 10 years impress
look at my prison [ __ ] I was a knife guy
I worked in the night yard or some [ __ ]
he goes I quit lights my body still used
to lights it was every time I'm [ __ ]
up I'm late for work because they
[ __ ] pissed me and they piss you on
the way out they don't even come to your
room and not in there so now you're
already running late to work you must
Norton bloke before 30 you got one hours
sleep and they stopped yet the door no
way excuse me don't [ __ ] pin you
ain't got no pee in it so you have two
hours
see you got away you got away so you
gotta sit and read drink water fun you
can leave but when you come back and be
they sit right there with the mirrors
the whole thing change
what are they doing mirrors they watches
yeah
taking the Galatea nutsack yeah but I
can't beat them man
I beat him for months undefeated they
caught me they caught me two times but
you gotta assume they hit me with
[ __ ] fully [ __ ] piss test by the
time they got me with the second or
third percent but that's they just play
the field like anything else yeah I got
him I got him because I would time it I
played it clean just to watch them and
watch how they would maneuver off my
reactions so if I came home late from
selling a car I knew I got pissed tested
you don't saying even though when you
come in a breathalyzer you are the best
car salesman ever yeah I could picture
that but that was the thing they in the
first two or three months I play them so
why didn't you just try not to get
tested boobie yeah because after a while
they just played but after a while I got
to know that tendencies and I knew what
they would do so what I did was I can't
stayed clean but for that I got greedy
and I was selling coke and I would pick
it up with my hands and it would go
through your skin and one time they got
me out of that really yeah go through
your pores no way it goes through must
be making up a lot of code yeah you pick
your weight up and else when you wake up
announcer it's [ __ ] right off the
[ __ ] battle boy whose point five at
least yeah you know it goes looking your
fingers yeah you're doing the whole
[ __ ] thing so I didn't realise I came
up at that time one time and then
another time I came up on three months
later so I could so they thought about
this or they thought about putting me in
rehab I cut a deal with them I cut it
out of those six to nine reacts like six
o'clock at night the nine at night when
they talked to you before then they let
me back and I got back to level four and
that was it but yeah dog I uh
that's crazy that is [ __ ] crazy and I
still think about that [ __ ] like laughed
my ass floor but yeah they pissed me I
watched them for the longest time
because that was locked up they didn't
pissed me at all the rumor was they were
gonna they peed people yeah they peed
the old junkies
but they didn't pee and then we started
they said that you couldn't get tested
for acid so we so last night we did a
simple prison you know there's a sale on
acid today guys good acid me the
librarian he was a genius either double
attack get a group on there was no gonna
bug there was bought obedience
there was no Mexican medians is enjoy
how the last place I want to do a sit
boy Wow did oh just makes you think
about all the terrible things you like
you've done in your life and then even
then then you I have panic attacks and
they're already I'm presently that's you
because you planned everything you think
everything oh yeah when I did the acid
there I want to think about my life and
where I was going and what opportunities
and what possibilities I had that's it
only you captain doom because I think
you're [ __ ] dungeon Jew DNA
disrespect the Chanukah holiday Happy
Hanukkah didn't take a [ __ ] like that
you say that's a son that's why people
have whenever somebody tells me they
have a bad trip I laughed my [ __ ]
because guess what hi out trip them
might three hundred heads I'm gonna look
you in the eye and tell you I never had
a bad trip one time I turn off the
Exorcist when you is my birthday my turn
17 happy right before that I bought a
[ __ ] me and a bunch of savages went
out to Union City and we bought a ten
dollar bag of THC crystal aka [ __ ]
the horse tranquilizer
aka [ __ ] haze this was way before
that [ __ ] too soon when you were doing
angel dust it was just a modified angel
doesn't buy ya come in
it was a bother fine angel dust then you
could snort we were probably I don't
know what the [ __ ] am I talking about
his angel does he back then and a
Halloween [ __ ] the first time I did it
probably 30 to 14 Jesus will have
fathers tremendous I know because you
can't wait for that well totally gets it
it's not bad it has a little bit of star
actor
it smells like was goomy's hermanos
hahaha no I love snoring that [ __ ] made
you feel like Gumby dust but the first
time I went down there
what does that even mean Gumby dust you
just feel also off to shamela Gumby and
pokey yeah of course
okay dad there's a little child okay
Gumby thin member Gumby was all been
anything like that right that's it you
feel like Gumby
your eyes are almost shut shut he's ours
no son stop probation I'm on probation
so no no no so we would go down we went
down in one night I think I did that and
a [ __ ] in a hit ass and I went home
when I put on the Exorcist to watch but
I put blacks out of master reality on to
listen to and that was the first time
I'd take the earphones offering oh this
is ugly this is not good this is not
[ __ ] good I'm gonna do a hairy butt
besides I never had a bachelor party
even after the death of my mother
actually cleaned up my head dog because
I would think about my life and I would
think about my mom and then we kind of
put everything into perspective nice and
I just let me tell you some I want you
do me a favor sure let me talk to you
about torture okay okay this is
man-to-man
my favorite album at night when I would
come home at night and I would be like
in the daytime I'd be with Jack and
Vinny and and D'Agostino by your
mother's house and your mother's old my
mom had died so she didn't fight me off
dinner at night I become family and then
I go home and take a shower I was
staying you picked me up you know it was
that type of lifestyle or the farm goal
with just what we told him like it was
you co-stars it me to me do you guys see
a lot of thought I mean you still have a
start right there I might mean that one
he has teeth yes these are choice your
eyes are closed right now no we're
talking about [ __ ] bad trips and I
would never think that way Lee that's
what I'm trying to say to you
have you ever took it I gave me the time
we did it somebody put that compilation
of you giggling right well that's so
funny
yeah you couldn't you were having a
great time you know one thing
all bad but it is scary no no no oh I
want you to put on Black Sabbath
megalomania okay come over there
I would at night at night I would go
after I do the Hitler acid I would go
home and take out a couple lines of coke
and play this song and play real quick
okay one sample why is it taking so long
what's going on dog you slipping and
[ __ ] I smell them you know just put
Black Sabbath right and by the time you
get the mega I'll come up on the zone
mango mania mg M eg le ma ni a something
like that got no [ __ ] Spelling Bee
champion I just try Russian think about
[ __ ] being on acid and there's I
would torture myself
put this out loud
I'll speed up
you go
this one's missing too
this is my self torture
I heard this on the radio the other
night
it's very emotional for you know that
walk why look [ __ ] emotion now I'm in
the buck when you're driving know what I
hope you know no I just heard this and I
don't listen I don't have the sound in
the office
ah - listen person live with me this is
as scary as it gets with me
oh yeah [ __ ] that owner my garage though
it's bad but kick it up kick the Beulah
this is my ass
by right here I'd be the Polish achingly
stop it stop it
and our zebra here
the ghosts of tomorrow from my favorite
dream is telling me to leave a song are
you [ __ ] kidding me
this would go through my head
you keep slipping away slipping in
tomorrow
are you [ __ ] nice 17 this is why I
don't give a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] Bimini
mrs. soules immediately
the listen to this you're gonna be a
[ __ ] get another
what he says here he just goes after
ours is like the north sex candles those
things nothing is nothing they were
[ __ ] the Kings this is 1975 they were
going up and gets out John they were
going up against the Eagles are you
[ __ ] kidding me
but no this is the acid trip short
anyway on that note Jack you're having
your what your 40 anniversary party this
one's the comedy yeah so I'm happy you
came on I think appreciate that means
December I wanted to put John under yeah
Merry Christmas man thank you hi
everybody was invited by didn't come
because I was tired I understand I fell
asleep I was a long flight I means a lot
five [ __ ] show's been very supportive
you know I love you [ __ ] and I want you
to come back and learn how you feeling
over there [ __ ]
I'm feeling really I believe for having
a happy Chanukah to you and your family
thank you call your family a mall more
than what's the story I'm alone oh yeah
absolutely felt he hasn't presents for
people but it's gonna be good holiday
and I can feel the air - speaking of
presents every year millions of people
received the least light gift of all
time underwear but we still give it to
our family our loved ones who just don't
want it but maybe it's not the under way
it's a problem and see I'm the kind of
under way you're giving them let me tell
you about the best underwear out there
me on these the only underwear that
makes for an amazing gift
I love me on this you guys know I've
been talking about a few years love of
the death I won't to jiu-jitsu I went to
a gym when I have shorts on they're soft
to death flexible waistband three times
softer than cotton and naturally
sustained short fiber me undies main
underwear that perfect gift that
everyone's gonna love for you it's a
goddamn holiday miracle this year
don't give him underwears giving me on
these cut to [ __ ] this holiday season to
get your exclusive
20% off the softest underwear and socks
you'll ever wear free shipping and
percent satisfaction guarantee listen to
me if you don't know what to get your
loved one for a Christmas present these
are the best and best thing in the world
pick up some crazy color and send them
the socks and the under way that's what
I'm gonna do for you I'm gonna give you
20% off all right I'm gonna give you
free shipping and on top of that you get
uncle Joey's and me undies on a percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me on these
dot-com slash Joey
that's me undies dot-com slash Joey
number two listen the holidays mean one
thing go go go
you got presents travel relatives with
all that it's tough but you're gonna
find time it's hard to find time to eat
healthy let nature box help with the
snacks that are both delicious and
better for you if you're trying to eat
better
the holidays are in minefield right
chocolates cookies candies canes
it's no fun feeling left out the
deliciousness let naturebox help with
snacks you'll love the seriously
delicious and better for you the
holidays are not always a holidays you
got stuff to do people to shop for and
cheer the spread all right naturebox has
over 100 Alysha snacks the snacks are
all made with high-quality simple
ingredients
this means no artificial colors flavors
or sweeteners alright from the honey
crunch crisps to the sour cream and
onion straws to the blueberry almond
Quino quinoa quinoa whites listen to me
all snacks are made no other official
colors flavors a sweetness it's easy go
to nature box calm and nature box will
deliver them right to your door loose
knacks are added every month inspired by
new food trends professional chefs and
customer feedback my favorite snacks
like I've been telling you guys for
years I've never done the vanilla bean
wafers I love the dark cocoa nom noms
I love the garlic plant
I loved the mini peanut butter oatmeal
cookies and I could go on and on and on
and on and on all right there's no risk
and if you don't like to snack they
state your box replace it for free
listen to me it's the holidays and right
now the church or what's happening down
my family I'm gonna offer you 15% off
your first daughter when you go to
nature box.com slash Joey that's
naturebox.com/tyler s'en it's healthy
stay healthy over the holidays and start
2018 with the health kick right or wrong
why you gotta start 218 - thing I go to
the gym forget about it go to naturebox
calm down and get 50% off your first
dollar that's naturebox.com/tyler a
naturebox calm
now you're eating healthy and you got
nice underwear but if you [ __ ] stinks
like ten dead camels what good is it
right or wrong that's why when you're
writing your Christmas list to Santa
this year tell that [ __ ]
that one he still owes you money and -
or you want for Christmas is your
[ __ ] to be [ __ ] tip-top Magoo when
you got access to pine cones and
dingleberries hanging from the [ __ ]
bowels of your [ __ ]
and that budgie pulley smell all over
the [ __ ] sides I'm holy night nobody
wants you at the house
you need a cushy birthday it'll clean
your ass better than any [ __ ] toilet
paper on the market right you know why
it clues it uses clean water to spray
that muffler providing you with a shower
fresh feeling after every [ __ ]
monster [ __ ] that comes out of your ass
let me look at you you're a [ __ ] Mook
the Lord
you realize [ __ ] wait things gonna come
out of your ass flowers and roses and
that [ __ ] sticks to the corners is that
what you want even if you take a [ __ ]
and you wipe it all that mildew and
horror sticks to the corner your [ __ ]
next thing you know you're walking
around with a cane all right no more
skid marks no more sugar burns fairies
hanging an ass crack just an [ __ ]
cleaner than a white Christmas they now
come and millennial pink and
blue to add a pop to color to your
bathroom and even to models with fancy
bamboo knobs and they start at $69 Santa
can afford this all right it's just $69
so stop wiping with that [ __ ] nasty
toilet paper and get a clean ass with
tushy
go - hello - she calm and use promo code
church to get 10% off your order I want
to thank Jack as a durian jr. listen if
you see him in a comedy club opening for
some money you got the seal of approval
he works hard
he's got heart and if not he wouldn't be
on this show tonight and I want to thank
my little boom ba teach over there the
[ __ ] and I want to send I wanna
wish him and his family a [ __ ] special
holiday them because I love them how do
you say Italian again
Mott's Oakley store I love you
[ __ ] Wednesday will start
earlier Rick Ramos get your paper get
your pencils and paper it's gonna be
more of a video type podcast don't
forget Feliz Christmas present when you
go to Amazon click on the church what's
happening now banner right go to the
Joey go to join Ian and there's an
Amazon bear over there click on there
Feliz I add you know I love you
[ __ ] have a great night and
we'll see you guys Wednesday stay black
amazing
[Music]